foreign
good afternoon and welcome to today's
Richard M carp distinguished lecture I'm
Sandy Irani and I am the associate
director of the Simons Institute
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
with the Simons Institute we are the
leading international venue for
collaborative research in theoretical
computer science established in 2012
with a generous Grant from the Simon's
Foundation The Institute brings together
researchers from all over the world in
theoretical computer science and related
fields and we also support the next
generation of young scholars
the goals of the Institute are to
explore the use of algorithmic thinking
in science and engineering as well as to
study the laws of computation itself
um we established this Richard M carp uh
distinguished lecture series to
celebrate the role of the institute's
founding director dick karp in his role
in establishing the field of theoretical
computer science outlining its Central
questions and contributing a stunning
array of results
um the series features Visionary leaders
in the field such as shakhar and
theoretical computer science and it's
geared towards a broad scientific
audience so we're very grateful to all
the many contributors to the Richard M
carp fund who have made it possible to
have this series and so today I'm really
very happy to welcome
professor at UCSD and he's made many
contributions in a broad array of topics
within theoretical computer science
complexity Randomness pseudor Randomness
algebraic constructions coding Theory
the list goes on and he's received
numerous awards for his work uh NSF
career Awards Sloan fellowship and a
Simon's investigator award so his talk
today is titled the structure of
communication so welcome
thank you Sandy and thank you for you
know you and everybody else at Simon so
invited me and I have to say I'm really
enjoying this Workshop so far this is
the first Workshop I've been to since
kovid so for the last three years so
it's been lots of fun
and then in the topic I decided to talk
about and also we had some talks during
this workshop on related topics is
communication complexity not just for
itself as a research area because I want
to use it as a way of highlighting how
questions that come up naturally when
you study various aspects of
communication and computation sort of
are connected and the shed light on
questions in mathematics with come UPS
of naturally in many different areas and
the topic of this Workshop is the
structural result so I would focus on
structure questions and and results that
come out of studying communication
and please you know if you have
questions stop me and ask that sort of
try to
prepare this talk to be sort of a
balance between
General audience and people in this
Workshop so I might
I know it's a
wide range so hopefully you know do
something for everybody
so
so what are the success story of
communication complexity
so this area was introduced in the late
70s by Andrea and his main goal was to
use communication as a way of
understanding a communication
bottlenecks in various areas within
computer science
and since then a lot of the work in this
field have been on identifying key
important problems that come up in
communication complexity and give some
list here for people who know the area
and what's important about them is it's
a natural product easy to embed in many
many other application domains so if you
understand them really well it means
that we understand really well many
other areas
and not surprisingly you know after
people have sort of spending now maybe
decades proving very strong lower bounds
in these for these problems uh they were
to be used to really understand
questions that how naturally in many
other domains in algorithms in in theory
classes in general
but this is really not the focus of my
talk today and what I want to focus on
uh sort of the challenges of
communication complexity
and I want to make the following point
that was being very successful with it
understanding concrete problems that are
important what we've been less
successful with this understanding
General problems and how their structure
gets connected to how well we can sort
of solve them using communication
complexity framework and if you don't
know this framework I'm going to explain
it in detail in a few slides
and
moreover the mathematical questions that
come up when you're trying to understand
these questions in communication
complexity sort of lead naturally into
various types of structural conjectures
that come up in many other domains and
and really what I want to do today is
try to share these connections
so here's the plan for today so I'm
going to start with a brief introduction
to communication complexity for the
people here in the audience who maybe
don't know this area well because it's
supposed to be a broad talk and then you
know there's many many areas within
communication complexity I chose to
speak about three of them one is the
simplest setup where you have two people
that talk without any Randomness and we
see even there there are many questions
we don't understand then we'll see what
happens when we add Randomness and the
picture becomes much more complicated
and then when we had even more players
it becomes even more complicated than we
took us we do it step by step
again this is not a complete you know
list of many more areas that I'm not
going to cover at all
so let's start with a brief introduction
to communication complexity so this is
the the setup we have some players and
for the most part we're going to focus
on two players Alice and Bob Ellie sells
her inputs and Bob has his input and the
goal is to jointly compute some function
together what do we make together so
they all each of them know their own
inputs and they have no Community No
computational Limit they have to compute
whatever they want and they trust each
other but they don't know each other's
inputs so they want somehow to
communicate with each other and together
jointly solve this sort of distributed
problem with the global input was
partitioned some part winter at least
and the other part went to Bob and again
there's no aspect of cryptography here
there's another aspect of trust
everybody trust Etc they just want to
solve this sort of computational problem
and the optimization goal is to minimize
the amount of communication going
between them
usually going to be some function of X
and Y that you want to compute
so how can we view such a Protocols of
mathematical viewpoints
so it will be very convenient to
identify such functions of two inputs of
matrices so how do we do it
so again with this function of two
inputs and we're really going to in our
mind think of it as a big metrics well
the rows are indexed by the inputs to
the first player X Alice and the columns
are indexed by the inputs to the second
player Bob and their goal isn't also at
least knows a row and Bob knows the
column they want to figure out what's
written here at this row and column and
they want to do it while minimizing the
amount of communication between them
so what is a protocol let's see so
initially they know nothing right
everybody know their own input but they
don't have any shared information
and then let's say Alice speaks first
and she says one bit to Bob well what is
this one bit doing it's really telling
both the 12 if Ellie sends zero now we
know that the input is in some subset of
the inputs of Alice and if she sent one
it's in the complement sets so it's
really done is partition in the set of
possible inputs that they know where the
The Joint utilizing to these two halves
and I'm sort of drawing them here as
well as geometric rectangles but they
don't have to be contiguous it's just
easier to draw this way so this is some
substance of the rows and that's a
complement set
because it's the first bit so this is
what they know so far and now let's say
it's Bob's Store to speak so he sends
some bits B2 and this interpretation of
V2 depends on whether the top half or
the bottom half right because they know
where they are so maybe it's in the top
half now the Bob's bit is zero if the
input is in this half of the input and
other one in this part
and maybe in the bottom it has some
different interpretation
so you see as they keep sending beats to
each other what they're really doing is
partitioning The Matrix into like small
and smaller parts
so maybe now Ali sends another bit so
there's a another partition and so on
so at the very end a bit with a protocol
there is this partition of the metrics
and somehow and what they know is that
they initially they knew nothing about
whether joint input lies and at the very
end maybe they know that now it has to
lie here
another question how can that help us
compute a function
and here's going to be a difference of
whether it's deterministic or randomized
or whatever is our model
but this is a protocol we focus between
a function this is what a protocol
induces on the metrics it's a partition
so how what can you say about this
partition
so we said the protocol really
corresponds to this sort of recursive
type of Matrix partitioning
and here's the first observation if a
protocol sends C beats so C bits get set
from one plot to the other then it can
use the partition of the Matrix to 2 to
the power C rectangles right because
every time it's in the bit every
existing rectangle gets split to two
parts
so they do c times you get two to the
three rectangles okay so you can say
well you can identify protocols with
this recursive Matrix partitioning let
me see the just just so that it's clear
so this sort of exponential Gap in the
number of bits sent versus the number of
rectangles but this is just sort of a
scaling they should be the balls the
same thing
and now here's the first question that
comes up but what if we have this
General partition what if you don't have
this recursive nice Professor partition
what do you have this type of like Nano
cancer partition
does this also correspond to a protocol
well not directly
but here's the results the theorem that
yanakak is proven earlier 90s that well
you can slightly refine this
will get back into here and you don't
need many more rectangles
um so if I have a partition with some
number R rectangles it could be crazy
like that's a total recursive partition
you can slightly refine it and get
slightly more rectangles and you'll
slightly move it out to the logo so
slightly more than polynomial number
rectangles and that's going to be a
recursive partition which is the same as
being a airport
is called this a click versus
independent set problem because there is
a way of recasting this question as sort
of a game between a game on a graph and
one player knows a click and another one
is an independent set but anyway just if
you look at the literature this is a
buzzword around this problem
and for many years it wasn't clear you
know if this out of the logo is
necessary or if you can do better
but sort of a few years ago so Mika
Goose who's you know somewhere Mika and
Tony and and
what's on they prove that this is
actually necessary so this Gap to this
quality point and I will get that's the
truth there are functions where you
cannot do better okay
so at least
I want to say that for our purposes
looking on General partitions or
recursive partitions will not really
play a big part so this quasi polynomial
blow up is not going to matter because
very soon we see that there are many
many larger gaps that we don't
understand
so in your mind when you think about
collection protocols it's more or less
equivalent whether you think about
General partitions or recursive
partitions you can move back and forth
without paying too much
what does it mean that the protocol
computer function so software within a
function now we have a function so we
have some function let's say it's a
Boolean function and remember we
identify protocol with the partition to
rectangles
so for deterministic protocols one that
use no randomness
I claim that this means that the
politician the metrics into what is
called monochromatic rectangles when
rectangles where all the values of the
function are either all zero or all one
why because let's say the players played
and they ended up in this rectangle well
there's no more communication left
there's no Randomness they need to know
the answer so it better be the case that
all the inputs that met with this
rectangle give us the same answer so
this function must be monochromatic on
this rectangular
so again you can identify deterministic
protocols that computer function to a
partition of this Matrix of the function
into a small number of of monochromatic
rectangles and we would like to know
what's the smallest number you can do
now the other models we will soon see
randomized particles the players are
allowed to use Randomness and then this
picture becomes more complicated because
now they don't have to be correct all
the time just part of the time and we'll
discuss this later and you can get this
to unlock more complicated scenarios
like non-deterministic protocols and
more than two players and we'll see some
of them later today but for now I mean
if you've never seen this area before I
mean deterministic Protocols are a good
model to have in mind just a partition
of the metrics two monochromatical
standards
okay so this is all I want to say about
brief brief broken into uh complexity
and now I want to move to these three
topics ahead just looking at two players
and the talking about deterministic
protocols and I want to tell you about
this conjunctions I really like called
the low grain conjecture it tries to
understand the structure of these
protocols
so this is a reminder so we said we
identify functions with these Boolean
matrices and we identified deterministic
protocols with some way of partitioning
this metrics into monochromatic
rectangles and again the rectangles are
although I draw them here geometrically
they really are combinatorial
rectanglements electrons times the sets
of columns they don't really have to be
contiguous but I just draw another for
Simplicity
so here's going to be the first measure
of Interest the deterministic
communication complexity of a function f
so what is this it's you ask what is the
best protocol the best deterministic
protocol for computing dysfunction and
would be my best the one they send the
smallest number of bits between the two
players
and like we said you can more or less
equivalently identify it with asking
what is the best partition of this
Matrix into monochromatic rectangle then
take log of that so up to some Square
factors are more or less the same so
either way either Viewpoint is fine
and the first question that you might
ask from a computational perspective is
this a number that's easy to compute
now Intuit intuitively it doesn't seem
like something that is the compute
because it seems like a vault maybe
chromatic number of graphs or some other
anti-hard problems so it's natural to
ask is this a quantity that's easier how
to compute
and the answer is it's hard
um in what sense is this hard
so there are two lines of work that show
the hardness one that's obviously
that well if you make some cryptographic
assumptions on
you know then we can prove this is that
it's how to compute
and but we really believe that this is
NP hard to compute but we don't know how
to prove it so there's a line of work
that shows that for weaker models or for
related problems this is in fact NP hard
and for example the this world of Hira
ilango and love that shows that some
version of this but not quite a related
version isn't we had and this is ongoing
work trying to really show this is a
hard problem similar to Chromatic number
it's the NP hard problem so surprisingly
we don't know how to prove it
and but this works so that well
understood reasonable assumptions you
know who it is exactly or approximately
too well it's probably hard so if you
want to understand this from a
computational perspective we should
probably look for some weaker
approximation that maybe are more
feasible to compute
this is one you put narrative but
something else that's connected to that
this is how it's called The Log rank
lower Bond and that would be this What's
called the logarian conjecture
so remember this sort of setup we had if
our function
with a protocol deterministic protocol
that sendsy bits
then there'll be a way of partitioning
this Matrix into two to the C
monochromatic rectangles
but
here's the first you see this is going
to be the first lower bound ever proven
in communication complexity so I'll say
no and it says well here's a way of
showing that you cannot do it
the the claim set we're going to prove
it in a second if you view this as a
matrix and you ask what's the rank of
this Matrix it cannot be very high why
is it why cannot be very high because if
my Matrix can be partitioned in this
case so let's say
rectangles because it's a partition you
can write as a sum of these rectangles
every rectangle is either a rank one
Matrix like this one or a ranked zero
Matrix like this one so overall the ring
because it's a it's a subjective measure
of the whole Matrix is at most the
number of rectangles so the rank is as
much two to the C so in particular it
says if my Matrix are just taking logs
here if my Matrix happen to have a large
rank then it's deterministic combination
complexity has to be large
so this is one technique the first
technique ever invented to prove some
lower bound on communication complexity
okay so this seems like a very naive way
of proving lower bounds here so
uh what can we say about it
so first of all to notice is that
we didn't identity over which fields to
complete directly it's a matter it's a
Boolean Matrix we can do it over the
reels of the finite Fields you can
choose your own field but because this
is the law of one we will try to
maximize the rank and to maximize it
right we just walk over the reels the
other rank is going to be the loudest so
whenever I talk about rank it's always
going to be over the reels
and then there's this very surprising
conjecture called the logarian
conjecture
by Nova sales tax from the late 80s that
says well
this would be this is also this lobe and
seems like it's sort of very naive it is
actually tight maybe up to some loss but
not a big loss
um
so this is what I want to tell you about
so this is a logarithm conjecture
it says let's read this together take
any Boolean metrics
whose rank is some number are
then you know it's deterministic
communication complexity is at most
logarithmic you know up to some Concepts
so what I want to do for the next 10
minutes is so look at this conjecture
and tell you how this conjecture
although I phrased it now in the
language of communication complexity
actually came up sort of more or less
independently at least four or five
other fields and now this is all the
things that gets connected together
so so far it seems like a very specific
conjecture about stocks of protocols but
we'll see soon why it's not much much
broader conjecture that might initially
seem
so but a few comments first of all
notice this conjecture connects two very
different domains it connects
combinatorial properties of matrices
like protocols or partitions with sort
of linear algebraic properties that rank
which the two things seem to be very
unrelated in general but it's conjects
to be related with the matrix's Boolean
some comments like I told you you need
to do it over the reels copy the rank of
a small file and films we know this as
follows
also we know this constant cannot be too
small we know it has to be at least two
and I'll get a little bit later
um
and another reason why this conjecture
is interesting because if you believe
this conjecture is true
then this will give us a an efficient
way of at least approximating the
deterministic combination complexity of
the Matrix why we notice that at least
the logarithm and if it suits at most
some polynomial in that and the rank is
something that's easy to compute
right so that's one way of saying that's
one way of approximating up to some
polynomial factors the communication
complexity of an arbitrary function yes
I give you a matrix and then Matrix that
yeah
a chromatic number it's a whole product
right even how to approximate but it
wasn't speculating that for this product
we could do it within a polynomial
approximation you can basically
fundamental
approximation results
[Music]
so this result will be Global also give
Logan for some good approximation
that will be Quantum Factor
approximation on stuff like that but not
beyond that
so I think another reasonable question
to ask is can you find a different
algorithm to approximate this thing even
if it's not based on rent and people
have thought about it then nobody had
any clue but I think that's a good
question
okay so what do we know about this
conjecture
so one thing that's easy to prove and
actually let me sort of show you the
proof here for people who didn't see the
proof is that it's very easy to show
that there is some bound here the trend
will congestion display log rank bound
but really if I just allow you to do
something that's exponentially big just
a rank then this is easy to put so let
me just at least show you this proof so
no
I guess every talk should have at least
one proof and it's better if it's a
simple proof so that's that's different
um so why can you always if you have a
low rank Matrix why can you always find
like an efficient portable for it so
here's one way to do it here's a matrix
let's say it's an n-bane Matrix
and it has
right r
so let's just for simplistically assume
that the first are columns
spend linearly spend all the other calls
with some alcohols do it so let's just
put multiple first our columns
and we also know this Matrix is Boolean
right so all the entries
or zeros and ones
so what do we know if we took a row here
and we look on this row
the claim that knowing the values in
this row
but himself you can without knowing any
extra information you can just deduce
all the other
entries in this role because all the
other columns are linearly dependent on
this column you know the metrics right
so if a gig is these elements here
then you can you know everything
basically so this is a protocol the role
player is just going to send these R
Beats to the other player and now
basically they know the row they just
can just look here on their column
and until what the value is so this is
being R plus one bits okay
okay this is simple but we believe this
is exponentially far from the truth
so a few years ago I approved I improved
this by about a quadratic Factor
and so that's on the upper bound side on
the lower bound side the best thing we
know so far from this paper I mentioned
before is that there are matrices
whose deterministic communication
complexity is at least log are squared
So within logo is relatively easy but
they walked out and got logar Square and
and so this is this content has to be at
least two okay
so we know something but they still see
that this is still the exponential Gap
in between two quantities
okay so what do we do now
so
what I want to tell you is sort of okay
I want to leave this picture as is for
now and what I want to tell you now is
how this problem about it seems like
it's a very communication specific
problem actually came up naturally in at
least four other different domains
um
okay so if you think about this
logarithm conjecture what it's really is
asking about in you have a matrix that's
Boolean and low rank what can you tell
me about it
and this seems like a very natural
mathematical problem so it's not
surprising that it came up in many other
domains as well
I didn't tell about a few of them
um
here's one this would still seem similar
to the previous one but you get a small
twist let's say we have an N by n
Boolean Matrix of low rank this
conjecture speculated that this metrics
must contain a large monochromatic
rectangle how large will the side of the
Matrix divided by some quasi polynomial
bounds okay
that's interesting I mean if you think
about the logarithm conjecture it
speculates something stronger it says
well not only you can find one such
rectangle it's monochromatic you can
actually partition the entire Matrix
into monochromatic rectangles so this is
like a vehicle conjecture but that's
equivalent so those work by listening
from the mid 90s that sort of show that
if you can do this genetically the way
to recurse it and actually be the whole
partition
so if you want to prove the lobbying
conjecture it means you don't need to
find the whole partition just find one
large rectangle and just recurs on that
that makes it easier for us but this is
still a very combinatorial uh let's say
Viewpoint so here's another one this
isn't coming from graph Theory
so that should be a graph then a b The
adjacency Matrix for this graph
it's really conjecture
came up in graph series that is this
adjacency Matrix says low rank then the
chromatic number of the graph is at most
quasi polynomial in the rank
well this seems like a weird conjecture
to speculate so in fact
this question of that sort actually came
up in in the 70s and 80s by valufeline
and
problem and actually originally the
conjecture much stronger you know
connection like why conjecture what's
the problem initially conjected if this
is
false well if this is polio so the
butterfly with your conjecture then
basically at the end of the day it was
realized that these conjectures in graph
Theory are completely equivalent to the
logarithm conjecture so like I said
there was a sequence of work started
with a alone
refuted the earlier conjectures either
formative language of graphs or in
language of communication complexity but
also these two conjunctions are in fact
equivalent to each other
so since the dislogram conjunction is
also a conjunction graph Theory
but some ways of bonding the chromatic
number of graphs
but here's another way this would be a
geometric formulation
so let's say I give you end points in
some d-dimensional space and some n
hyperplanes in the dimensional space
and I tell you that well
the point is at distance one for some
hyper plane so you have hyperplanes
collection of hyperplanes
you have points
the guarantee that every point because
distance one for some hyperplane but you
know you don't know for which side it's
going to be other top or bottom
yeah
so here's a conjecture coming up from
discret geometry it says well you could
find a large set of points and a large
set of hyperplanes where all the points
on the same side of all the Hybrids all
the points are in some polytope span by
the hyperplates so I was phrasing it
like that so it's the connection maybe
to the original the previous solution is
clears that so this will just be
connected in the inner product Matrix
but you know the way it was formed
originally doesn't I mean the
connections were maybe less clear
um
so let's say this could this conjecture
that coming up in in this geometry turns
to be equivalent and that is very nice
paper by singular and Sudan from from
last year where they studied this and
some other generalizations and all of
them cannot be equivalent to this local
conjecture so
um so all these questions in this great
geometry also end up being equivalent so
here's another one that maybe is a
little bit more surprising something
called that negative rank so I want to
Define this question with this notion
because it's going to come also later in
the top
so what's the story here so linear
programs in general are a very useful
commonly tool commonly used tool in
optimization
and in the 90s there were a sequence of
paper people said oh I can prove this
and I can solve this empty heart problem
using this sort of super sophisticated
linear program
and so it became harder and harder to
find bugs in these papers
did in the in the 90s to say well let's
develop a general technique to prove
that none of these things is going to
work
so this is no
reject all these papers at once right
you don't need to check them nothing
like this is going to work
and he did this by developing this whole
system of showing that this complexity
of linear programs can be characterized
by a quantity called non-negative rank
of some Metric that are not going to
find you called the slack Matrix that
sort of is defined by this linear
program
so I just want to talk about this
non-negative event
so what is non-negative rank so that FB
some metrics with negative entries
so what's the standard rank so the
standard rank of the Matrix one way to
say to say well it's a minimal R they
can decompose my Matrix as the sum of R
rank 1 matrices right that's the
standard usual definition of rank of
matrices
what's non-negative rank it's the same
thing except that we required all of
these matrices in the the composition
having the rank one but they have
non-negative entries
this is the negative rank played like a
huge part in this program developed by
anakakis
and for General matrices means the
result examples where the non-active
rank is huge compared to the rank but
there is this conjecture that says it's
for Boolean matrices there are no big
gaps no more or less the same
and again this is all equivalent to the
slogan conjecture
so I mean the goal of material or these
different sort of formulations is just
to showcase the discretion that is
really a question about structure of
lowering Boolean matrices came up with
at least five different domains the
smallest independently so it's a very
natural equation to try and understand
and really understand it very poorly
just to summarize deterministic
protocols
so let me tell you the feministic
protocols are a partition of a matrix to
multiple rectangles
there's this log rank which is a lower
bound a very simple lower Bound for the
deterministic communication complexity
there is this logarian conjecture that
says it's also an upper bound up to some
polyfactors
and that this question is really a
question that has nothing to do with
communication it's really a question
about structure of low rank Boolean
matrices which I think is a supernatural
mathematical question that we want to
understand better
so I'm going to move to the talking
about randomized protocols next so first
are there any questions about anything I
said so far
so or maybe for that one more thing
so there's
since we don't really understand how to
prove this logarithm conjecture for the
feministic protocols
it makes sense that you want to consider
some interesting special cases that's a
good way to make progress right in
general in research in your stuff
and turn that this special class of
function that called listed functions
where on the one hand we have enough
interest in structure that you can sort
of study them and get interesting
properties of them and learn new things
and on the other hand they're simple
enough that we can actually prove
something about them it's interesting
I'm not going to Define them at all
I just want to to say that people are
interested in this line of free so just
be aware that this area exists there's
ton of stones of research on it and it's
sort of looking in a special case on the
one hand but it's on the other hand it
connects all this question in the
communication world to the simpler world
of coil complexity in Boolean function
some people have talked about over this
week and a lot of these very fascinating
connections between these two Fields I
think I'm not going to talk about this
at all because no I only have an hour
so okay let's move to randomized
protocols so here's the picture pictures
will become even less clear
so what are randomized protocols
so we now allow the players to use
Randomness so up until now there was no
Randomness everything was deterministic
but now that they will we're going to
give the players a next star results
they can use randomness so what do you
even mean by user Randomness so there's
two models that make sense here
one is this model it's called private
Randomness so every player has their own
source of Randomness but it's secret
Only They Know It
the other model is called public
Randomness that says well there's this
in the cloud This Global source of
Randomness that everybody can use maybe
it's the beauty is a file or something
some Global randomness
and for the most part the stimulus are
more or less equivalent except for some
minor issues it's people who know them
know them people don't shouldn't care
and but today just for you know
Simplicity I'll talk about public
randomness
but again if you don't know these models
they're more or less equivalent
final differences
well that's what public randomness so
let's copy that'll be some source of
shared Randomness that everybody gets
access to
so what does it mean to run a randomized
protocols here's one way to think about
it so we sample this joint public
Randomness and based on that we run some
deterministic protocols so you can think
about a randomized protocol
as really some distribution over
deterministic protocols
and so you can imagine you have a bunch
of these sort of partitions each
corresponding to some deterministic
protocol you have some distribution over
them and you choose one of them and just
apply it to a matrix
what does it mean that this computer
function well now that it's randomized
well you do the usual thing you want to
say well for every input I want to be
corrected high probability
so you choose one of these partitions
and you want it for every input you get
the right value with let's say 90
probability
so again let's let's there's another
notation randomized communication
complexity of f is going to be well if
you're allowed to use randomized
protocols what's a minimal number of
bits you could use so this would be
align Randomness into the picture
okay let me show you two examples of
roundness protocols the first one
probably many of you have seen the
second one maybe less if you have seen
um so equality so let's say the two
parties want to check if the inputs are
equal so what can they do well first of
all what is a matrix Viewpoint of that
well equality should be one if the
inputs are the same should be zero
otherwise we just want to compute the
identity Matrix right so here's the
identity Matrix one player knows a row
the other planet of the column they want
to see if they're the same because they
get one
so one thing we can already prove just
based on what we've seen today is this
has now this does not have any
non-trivial deterministic protocol why
because the identity Matrix has rank n
it's a full rank Matrix so this low rank
lower bound says well you need to send
at least Logan bits but Logan bids just
send the whole inputs so this is a
trivial protocol
but I want to show you now that using
Randomness public Randomness to be
precise you can just do the concept in
many of these so you can say with the
number of bits that you're sending so
how do you do that
so here's a protocol so we're going to
use the public Randomness that's and to
think of it as we're really describing a
hash function from a domain n to let's
say 100 so I'm large enough constant
what are the players going to do well
they know this public
and hash function and they're just going
to apply to their own input privately so
they get each one a number between one
and a hundred and then just Compare the
numbers and see what they just replace
these numbers and why is that going to
work well because if the two inputs are
equal then they're always going to get
the same answer
but the difference are not equal like
with 99 they're going to get different
answers for the hash function I'm going
to reject so this is a very easy way of
using um
Randomness and actually for you know
some years you know some of our thoughts
is this the only way that you can use
Randomness but does not know there are
other ways you can use Randomness that's
not the only way but it's a very good
way of using Randomness like in most
cases where people use Randomness and
protocols that's all they do and then
apply more stuff on top of that
okay but actually another difference in
randomness
and which is again this is a
function that was discussed today in one
of the talks this is going to be the
Hamming Cube function so
your inputs are X and Y for now n bit
strings
and what you want to figure out is that
if X and Y form an edge in the hanging
queue which is just offensive way of
saying they differ in exactly one bit
so what you want is to figure out if you
know you have your X is let's say you
know X1 X2 X N and Y is y1 Y2 up to y n
if there's a single bit well they differ
you see maybe a zero hero and a one here
or the other way around
this is also something that we know we
can do efficiently and this is this
actually you know I learned in this
paper of lyanna and puya and Muhammad
were all here somewhere
um
it's really nice a protocol so what do
you do here well first thing just make
sure X and Y are different so you can
reject so using the equality protocol we
saw on the left slide just reject if
they're the same
otherwise use the following sub 14 10
times so it's a subutin
you know the news of public Randomness
to randomly sample a set of coordinates
one or two uniforms every coordinate
appears what we have
and I'm going to check is this tool with
X and Y differ on the status of
coordinates and they also differ on the
complement sets if this happens you know
then again we can reject
because they Define at least two
coordinates and if after run this 10
times you didn't reject then you accept
and this you can show this only accepts
X and Y to different exactly one
coordinate that's not how to show
so that's a different way of
using Randomness to sort file it doesn't
seem that maybe that obvious how you use
Randomness to solve
so here these were two examples so what
can we say about randomized protocols
so we know that for deterministic
protocols there is very nice
combinatorial Viewpoint as well the the
same as a partition to rectangle so it
was a very nice combinatorial way of
characterizing them we had this
logarithm conjecture that tried to
character item using linear algebra can
we do similar things for randomized
protocols
basically they want to argue that the
answers in general we don't know like
already there we are many things we
don't know
so let's try let's try to do that
so what did let's remember what we did
for the feministic protocols we said
well if the deterministic communication
complexity of a function is C then it's
ranked at most utility and we use it to
prove the logarian lower bound
you can do something similar in the
randomized world and say well if the
randomized communication you see then
some other notion of frame called the
proximate rank is also small
and I mean I have a definition here but
when it doesn't really matter I mean
there's some notion of rank with also
character like seems to characterize
randomized communication
and
and you can search for example there are
examples that may be the equality
function of the identity Matrix well the
rank in this approximately very
different of each other and one hope
with people here is that well maybe
similar to the logarian conjecture will
rank with a little Bond maybe this
approximate rank is a characterization
or this to some extent of randomized
protocols and why not
so in fact Lee and Schreiber made the
following conjunction that is exactly
the analog of the logarian conjecture
except that we replace deterministic
protocols with randomized protocols and
we replace rank with a proximate rank
and for like several years this was open
and people tried to prove them they
failed and then you realize that they
failed because it's false sorry okay
there was this sort of a really nice
walk by Chaturbate and Sharif a few
years ago where they give a counter
example but so this is a not just for
this is completely false
as fast as you want it to be so the they
give a very nice function called the
sync function I'm not going to Define
whose approximate ranking some number
are
but whose randomized communication is
not logarithmic it's polynomial in that
so really this is not the right way of
characterizing you know
um randomized communication using linear
algebra okay so what can we do well one
thing this teaches us is that if we
thought we more or less understand the
structure of lowering Boolean matrices
once you allow this low approximate rank
we have much richer structure so we
understand them much less and that this
very surprising example that come up so
seem to behave differently to what
people conjecture before the structure
should be
okay so you know can we use linear
algebra in any way to try and
characterize randomized communication
so we said this is approximate rank of a
matrix which was again definitely
slightly more formally it's just the
minimal rank of a matrix is approximate
your function
and if you remember we Define this
negative rig before so you can do the
same thing from the negative regular
password why do we do it well it turns
out you can use this measure this is the
proximate the negative rank is also a
lower Bound for you know randomized
communication
so you guys well maybe this is going to
be maybe you should replace a
proximately with that so there is a
conjecture that sort of a bit of a mouse
but I'm not going to read it here that
says well maybe
so there's a condition that says well
maybe if this is small we can do
something and nobody knows I mean might
be true might be false and the only
reason why I think this is a very
interesting conjecture is that it's not
that it's approximate the negative rank
is equivalent to a measure that people
use a lot in communication complexity
for low once it's called the smooth
rectangle Bond so if this conjunction
happens to be true it will show that
this lower bound technique that is a
very natural low band technique in
communication complexity is complete
maybe some polynomial factors and
currently we have no clue if it's
complete or not
so I think that's an interesting
conjecture
for people who like a structural
conjectures
um but now let's try to like you know
painful like you know let's lower the
balance the less ambitious goals since
we don't really understand the structure
of you know General randomized protocols
let's just ask can we say something
about super super efficient randomized
protocols one that just changed like
stage of two or three bits or 10 bits
can we at least understand them
okay so what functions have constant
randomized communication this is a very
should be a very simple question like
what functions are quite like you know
10 bits to compute if you use a
randomness
and we saw some examples but
here let me see quality or ham and Q but
in general data that we don't know
we don't have the classification
you don't but we really don't know we
know some examples
and
okay maybe thanks I'm going to skip this
slide there's some connection between
this and questions that come up in a
geometry and in machine learning or
maybe for the sake of time I'm going to
skip this
here's gonna ask me afterwards
and so here's a conject that came up in
part of this research that says well if
you have a function that has constant
randomized communication you should have
some combinatorial structure concretely
the conjecture it should have at least
one large monochromatic rectangle why do
we conduct that still well it's two the
two examples we know okay so maybe it's
two who knows
we really don't understand the structure
of
randomized protocols or even simple
functions like that are completely open
and
also more interesting I think that there
is also also really in the same paper by
by lyanna and and Muhammad
there's a slightly more General
conjecture that if it is true would give
a connection to a very surprising field
in algebra cultural algebras whether
some structural conjecture there that
ends up being sort of equivalent to
understanding the structure of
randomized communication protocols and
you can ask them later if you want
it's a very interesting surprising
connection
yeah
so just summarize what we know about
randomized protocol we really don't
understand I mean if we thought we don't
understand the Terminix protocols we
really don't understand randomized
protocols
there is some natural analog program
conjecture but it ends up being false
there's some refinement which may or may
not be true
and you know I clean it for
deterministic protocols or gaps are
quantitative we don't know what the
right bounds are for randomized
protocols we have qualitative gaps in
our understanding we don't even know if
something is constant or large I really
have no idea
yeah
okay so I'm gonna end talking about
randomized protocols so let's see if you
have any questions about that then I'm
going to move to the last part of the
topic it's going to be what if we add
more players into the next
are those two ways the only simple
functions that we know generalize
it's a great question find another
function
in general for the structural
conjectures finding more examples is
really useful
in order to rule out many conjectures to
understand what should be the right
special questions to ask so I think it's
really important to find more examples
tunnel
yeah
okay
so the last best thing I want to tell
you about is about what happens when you
add more polarized
so I'm just saying the one more players
three players
and even for three players already two
models that you you could consider and
I'll tell you briefly about both of them
one that's called number in hand one
that's called number on the forehead and
they both think shed different light on
the questions that's come up when you
add more pillars into the mix
and of course you can add more players
and do more models but but let's just
stick with these two simple models for
now
so there's this number in hand
so here's the model so you have three
players this is It's dog cat and owl and
each of them have their own input and
they want to copy the function so that's
like the most natural extension of the
two player model so having two plus now
we have three plus
so
remember for two players we said we can
identify a function on two pluses
metrics and we can identify protocols as
partitions of this metrics to rectangles
well there's something very similar
happens when you have three players now
instead of matrices you have three
dimensional matrices called tensors and
instead of rectangles you get cubes and
you get exactly the same behavior so
nothing special happens here
so it
is tempting to ask can we generalize the
logarithm conjunction to this domain as
well so
so what this will be the logarian
conjunction with the very natural notion
of rank of tensors that is the analog of
what you get the Matrix says and it's
easy to prove that it's still a lower
Bound for the deterministic meaning
complexity of this function this model
and you can ask well is this also an
upper bound
and so three separately doesn't any
Works to actually try to study this
question it's a harder question compared
to the logarian conjunction it contains
a special case so maybe we don't try to
prove it but maybe it's false or maybe
it's equivalent I don't know so I think
it would be very nice if some of you try
to understand what can you say about the
logarithm conjecture analog when we add
more players into the mix
that's me nobody tried to do it
Okay so
what is this awesome this was one model
this number in here the most natural
extension what's the other model the
other model is maybe less natural but
ends up being even more interesting this
is called number one forehead model and
if you've never seen this name before
it's very surprising why is it in all
this way so I'll tell you the second
but materials we should think about it
so you're going to be three players but
instead of now each and you have three
inputs but now each of them know knows
two out of the three inputs so there are
a lot of shared information between the
players each one of them knows two out
of the three inputs and they want to
still compute this function so it should
be easier for them right
by the way why is this name number one
forehead well in the original paper that
introduced this model by Chandra first
and nipton the use of vision this is the
card game where you know every one of
them has lists of cards stuck to the
head and you know they see all the other
inputs so if you came to lyanna's doctor
yesterday is really nice of cartoon
of that that's my best tool and I can
that this is my limit the Hindu cartoons
but so
um yeah so imagine they have the input
stacked with the head and they see all
the other inputs acceptable oh but you
know if you just think about each of
them you know in two out of the three
inputs maybe that's more convenient so
what can we say in this model
well because they know more information
it's easier to design protocols but on
the flip side it's harder to prove lower
bounds
and what I want to tell you that somehow
proving low bound to this model ends up
being super important and related to
many questions that come up naturally in
other domains
in particular I want to maybe spend two
minutes telling you about how question
the power I think natural and this model
gets connected to question a very
natural and additive from metallics and
and to me this connection is super
surprising and insightful
so tell me about two connections like
that
one of them that I think we've already
also heard about doing this Workshop is
this connection with something called
the corners problem and the exact n
pronoun so tell you what this is so
here's the corners problem it's a
problem it's a classical problem instead
of at least 50 years in Native computer
it says what is a corner you have pairs
of numbers in the range one through n
and the corner is just three numbers
that look like that so the difference
here is the same as the difference here
that's a chord and the question there is
what is the largest set in the grid one
up to n up to one up to n it does not
contain a corner so that's a classical
reality question
and there's been tons of fork on it and
we don't received another answer
but turn that to the communication
complexity problem that seems very
natural that is exactly identical to it
so what's the question here so you have
three inputs in the range one up to n
and the players just want to see if they
add up to n
that's it should be easy right and we'll
ask him but now each of them knows two
out of the three inputs
they're not going to use Randomness and
they want to still solve this function
so the surprising fact here is that
these two questions are in fact
equivalent completely equivalent
if you mean a solution here translated
solution here and vice versa and you
lose almost nothing
instead of this sort of
leads to the hope that maybe we can use
techniques coming from communication
complexity to try and improve our
understanding on questions in edited for
metrics maybe about another example like
that I think it is even more surprising
so another question is maybe for some
extent one of the crown jewels in a
remedy Theory and and in the diplomatics
it's called the health Dukes problem of
theorem
so it is one definition
so the we work in the domain of strings
of length n or whatever this is one two
three
I would say the three three percent x y
z form a combinatorial line sort of if
they look like that if in any column
either they're all the same or it goes
one two three
this is X Y and Z that's a combinatorial
and you get the same type of question
what's the largest set of
strings one two three to the N that do
not contain a combinatorial life and
there'll be tons of all this problem and
the bunsenal are really poor and this is
a really important problem in into the
friendly Theory and turn that to the
again an equivalent question for it I
think it's very natural in the
communication world so what's the
problem here
so the players receive
input another input or not numbers now
every input is a subset of the numbers
one through n
and the goal is just to check if the
three sets I got from a partition of one
up to n it sounds very natural and again
you want to do it without using any
randomness
a few years ago that these two questions
are again equivalent and I think that
it's very interesting to understand and
looking at other questions that come up
in additive commentatorics and memory
Theory do they have equivalent
formulations in this communication world
and already there have been some same so
for mild progress in improving bounds
and constants and Bounds in the uh the
Ramsay World using techniques and from
communication I think that a lot more
workers can be done in a lot more
connections that can be discovered
um one last thing so let's say one one
thing here because I think we'll run
start to run out of time so if you took
if you take functions
if you take functions in two players
it's very easy to come with examples
where Randomness actually helps it so
you can so okay quality we saw
deterministic you need basically the
only three little protocols but with
Randomness you can use other one it's
but when you go to more than two players
to this number on the forward model
really we didn't have strong separations
and the best separations we had came
from these separations that we had in a
in in Revenue Theory that's the corners
problem and so only recently you know we
were able this is with a xender Kelly in
ragameka to get stronger separations in
this NOS world
and it's so far don't directly connect
with problems in in ethical but they
have lots of inspired by them and policy
will discover more connections out of
the way
and
wait a little bit if you are interested
I'll just say here's a function that's
easy that's easy to State the function
at least
um that's easy for randomizing how for
deterministic so pick some large finite
field take vectors in some content
animation and Subspace that's 14 just a
large enough content and what the
players want to check is it's no if all
the you know process of the inputs are
the same or not and turns out this is
easy for randomize and this is a very
hard for the feministic and also here
also there's another direct connection
but the proof Builds on the side of the
head is helium neck had this really
breaks through results several months
ago in anti-probatorex and this builds
up on their techniques
so now the summarize so for this
multi-party protocols were these two
models one was this number in hand model
it was a natural extension of the two
player model and here this natural log
Rank 10 log Tangerine conjecture that I
really invite people to sort of
investigate so it's a very natural
question to study and on this number on
the forehead or this information that is
shared between the players
then the lower bounds you are really
intimately connected to very natural
products come up in remedy series and so
on just to go summarize the whole thing
I think that questions that come up in
communication complexity expose a rich
structure in a number of mathematical
you know areas and domains and they sort
of are connected to sort of interesting
problems that come up in a lot of
domains and we saw some of them today
and there are many that I haven't
discussed today and I think they just
give us many interesting problems to
explore so we see it thank you
[Applause]
okay
so do you expect that there should be um
number of forehead functions with like
Optimal
um
separation and balance questions
there's other nice Notions for cancers
like slice rig is it all helpful to look
at this in terms of
communication and
can actually
the
is there any uh Montreal upper bond for
log attention
try to think about it probably the
reason just was surprising to me well I
Was preparing this slide this question
is very natural but nobody it never came
up in the literature okay
so it will be a number of foreign
okay
so the first one to try to find a
collaboratory progressions well you
really don't know how to do it right
only very easy we will improve on for
free so maybe at some point
there are a lot of technical challenges
so having seen these protocols for the
first time
quality academic problem access to
relative advantage of the randomized
protocol in just a bit on the fact that
it sort of
much more likely intuitively that two
strings
yeah problem
or rather function where
the zeros and ones are more balanced and
still the randomized protocol has a
large amount let's say I want to check
with X and Y are different but then
solve it one then each curve be a second
or n beats that X and Y and then another
bit an extra method we want to solve
these two bits with the answer of
whether X is equal or not
not in an interesting way yes
it seem to be a structure underline the
ability to find a sufficient random
responsible but you still don't point
out what the structure is
a work showing that even if you have an
access to any quality product or it's
not enough yes
no I mean distance one doesn't have
questions
intersections
but
yeah
um I know that some prominent
theoretical computer scientists have
probably said that they think a lot of
rain conjecture is false if you have to
guess uh which way would you guess
injection is one of these conjectures we
actually have a lot of examples we'll
explain all of them so I think this is
more in my opinion it's more likely
between themselves because sometimes
like you know one example or two
examples there are families of examples
probably know it's true a lot of these
families
but at least we have more than one
example
yeah
thank you